this may come as a surprise but I have
myself some really really good
explaining to do because basically I
[ __ ] up many things as you may have
known I have been to London the sixth to
ninth of August which was awesome really
cool and I've Matt toothpick in FFI City
and done all kinds of cool things but
there's a couple of problems before I
went away I figured I would record three
episodes of the let's play and see how
that would go these episodes according
to the planning being episode 88 89 and
90 however there were problems with how
I rendered the video / recording issues
and they ended up being like switched
around in the in the titles that they
had so like I think episode know episode
89 and 90 were both combined into one
episode but then for episode 89 I think
I took the time lapse for episode 91 and
this is all basically very complicated
and I don't even know if I know it if I
understand what is even going on myself
but yeah the short story is I done
goofed I [ __ ] up and I'm currently
doing what is technically episode 90 so
this is actually the right episode in a
sense or at least it was called episode
90
however episode 89 was in fact really
episode 91 I didn't even see anybody
notice this but you may have noticed in
episode 89 there was the tree with some
planters around it that wasn't there
before the ugly building which I have
just removed in this video over here was
replaced by some simple facades that are
just here to just kind of be there and
look less terrible than the building
that was there before but still build a
placeholder over here and there's also
fence very spectacular but other than
that that wasn't really too much so
that's everything that's gonna be done
in this episode so yeah I am very sorry
I did [ __ ] up but I'm not even going to
restore all this and remake the videos I
reapplied them I'll just keep it up in
the same order as it is right now and
the short story is basically this is
episode 90 but it came before episode 89
as soon as I do 91 everything should
still be in order so really what
comes down to is there are many things
that went wrong but in the end it is
just that episode 89 and 90 were
switched around at least in the things
that I've done that being said in the
next episode I do remember I think I do
remember me saying at the end of the
video that I was going to be in London
which was a terrible decision like I was
going to record that before I went there
and now it's gonna be uploaded after
I've already been there and it's gonna
be really confusing but in any case I
have been in London at this point and
that was awesome and that's all past me
and so is all those [ __ ] up on
whatever I even did so I probably should
move to what I've done in Veliko second
three over here the only thing is that
I've already sort of summarized that hum
and I it's just simple stuff in this
episode really not that much was
happening I just opened up another
stream and figured there's a couple
problems with this pork and we're gonna
try and fix these problems or at least a
couple of problems and see how far we
got and basically what I got out of that
was the first thing was that this
building near the entrance of these
Spanish averages had to be removed that
thing was absolutely terrible it was
ugly it was a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it needed to be gone right now right the
second that I like said it basically
there were many problems with it I've
already complained many times about the
fact that the MDT
the t4l roof tile set has beautiful
tiled roofs but they're really lights
and they don't really work out with the
texture and all that the overall shape
of the building doesn't work too well
and even though I do think it was an all
right building it doesn't really work
for the cityscape that I have around it
it was way too much of a rural looking
building so that what that's why that is
now gone that being said I didn't know
what to really do with the facades
otherwise so I did still leave them
empty and I should have maybe done the
same with this thing over here because
that's basically the main issue right
now in the Spanish area is that I just
have this one corner which is next to
the the main square of the park which
connects to the facades that I already
have where I don't really know for sure
what I want to build over here but the
big issue with not knowing that is the
fact that I don't want to leave it empty
but every time I try to build something
over here it just turns out in
something that's like yeah it's alright
but not the sort of thing that I would
to have in this area so I might just for
the future leave this area open not just
because I'm lazy and I want to work on
it it's also sort of just to prepare
myself at some point maybe I might come
up with an idea that really fits this
area using which I can actually play
some buildings over here that really
work out well and don't have to look
terrible like the buildings are doing
right now so that was basically also at
that point in the video I also decided
okay let's not do that it's not going to
quite work out anyway so might as well
work on something else
I suppose that's never a bad thing to
really do as long as you do come back to
it but that being said this is a very
obvious facade and definitely something
that I'm gonna have to come back with to
come back to since it's just empty grass
right now and it's really terrible so as
long as it's something that you're gonna
have to come back to anyway I think it's
sometimes it's really good to just do it
at some other point in time so at that
point I figured that the path works
needed some stuff over here that's why I
decided to build a fence over here which
is at the time I don't know if I really
find it too much of a good idea at the
moment I still don't think it's the best
idea it's just really hard to fit
anything over here since one of the main
things that this park was going to have
was that you would see all of the
different themes that this park has
around the main square so in whichever
direction they are from the middle of
Eurasia you would see the types of
buildings so near the main street it's
just going to be the main street sort of
style now since this is the
Mediterranean area I did want to have
Mediterranean buildings next next to the
square over here but issue is on the
other side of that road over there I
wanted to have Dutch looking buildings
maybe English since that's what's going
to be the other side of the river but
the the big problem with that is that it
doesn't really connect to the other
Dutch and English themes and like I've
said before I don't really want to have
too much of that theme going on in this
spiral Spanish snow let me actually be
able to talk over here in the Spanish
area since that would just be terrible
so right now I decided to just leave
that empty and a fence over there maybe
some simple foliage but I might come
back on that plan anyway this is
something that I did feel pretty well
alright about I figure I went to have a
planter over here just to fill up the
emptiness we're very afraid of the
emptiness over here and this emptiness
just needed filling up over here I
figured with having these sidewalks it
is still a path that is five to six
tiles wide so it can definitely handle
the stream of guests that it might get
so I felt pretty safe just adding a
little planter action over here plus
that's always fun to do it's always just
I don't know I don't know of the I'm the
only person but I just feel like it's
just fun to get these little shapes in
here and see whatever shape works out
and then of course at the flowers but
everybody everybody knows already that I
really like flowers plus it just gives
me more room to we go around with
whatever I really wanted to do on the
other side since I was still very
undecided and placing flowers it's just
just an awesome thing it's I always come
back to that I always do that also at
some point I might add like if I if I
don't go through with the entire plan
over having foliage where right now
there's just a simple fence which is
gonna have foliage behind it because I
don't want a really break the Spanish
theme too much I might want to try and
add a tiny bit of a French theme on the
other side of this path maybe just a
tiny little square with some simple
buildings maybe something that looks
like an Eiffel Tower or something very
distinctly French because otherwise it's
gonna be really hard to make it look
very French but even though I wasn't
really planning on it I almost feel as
if I can't just skip France completely
that would be a terrible thing to do
that means that I don't to do that with
too many countries I can't that's that's
also a problem I can't fit every single
culture or country in well in this Park
that would make it way too huge or the
Aries way too small to work with so if I
do end up adding many more themes to
this park than I originally planned
which there should still be some room
for it to do it and then those are just
gonna be very small things I think that
Europa Park also sort of did that I mean
I have actually looked at Europa Park
and actually saw some common so people
who have been there I haven't been there
myself but
at least I think that some areas are
just really small like Russia has just
got a couple buildings the quote-unquote
Spanish area is just one little arena so
there really isn't too much through
these different areas so I might also
want to try stuff like that and just
make some some countries really small
over here but in any case I still want
to keep like the the big areas in the
park are not going to be the countries
that's something that I probably haven't
made too clear but the the park is
divided into areas which contain respect
to respective like similar countries so
basically over here this is the
Mediterranean area which is why it has
Spain and Italy at the moment and I do
just feel safe and in France do there
even though France doesn't really have
too much Mediterranean going on it is a
bit of a Mediterranean country also like
in the culture that they have and the
fact that they are well partly next to
the Mediterranean Sea and the area next
to this is going to be like the the
northwestern European countries being
Holland maybe a bit of Belgium Belgium
and England of course but I might still
be able to fit Island in there
though I'm not sure about adding that
next to England since that might give me
some trouble but I do feel pretty safe
about that and then obviously we are
going to have East Asia not so that's a
really easy one of course with Japan
that's a sure thing I might also want to
go into Chinese and very may be very
maybe alright a very may be Korea that
might happen but I'm not so sure about
that either
now I'm skipping areas I also wanted to
have a Alpine area we just got to have
Romania and yes I know that's not Alpine
but it does have some mountains and it
has similar sort of architecture and for
the other areas I still need to sort of
figure that out anyway in the meantime I
do see that I have been running out of
time and right now that not too much is
really happening anymore so I think I'm
gonna have to end it here as all the
flowers have been placed and all the
offenses have been placed and all the
sidewalk curbs are all
and everything I think it's time to say
goodbye so I'm gonna do that
and thanks for watching and I'll see you
on the next episode in which I am
actually going to do episode 91 real
this time